jamais jamais acheté des pages et à
montargis le point avec lui je sais pas
vous avez bandés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça oui comme ça
[Musique]
quels sont les trois premières lettres
du mot rhododendrons rouleau maire à
chaud
quel est le nom de l'étoile la plus
proche de la terre l'étoile la plus
proche de la terre c'est ma mère le
soleil il assure mme aw peut plus
rigoler combien font cette fois 8 x 8 56
si c'est bon j'ai plus question j'ai
gagné alors à si j'en ai d'autres hockey
sur glace ou doit aller un joueur qui a
reçu une pénalité prison comment
s'appelle le comédien qui jouait mr bean
mr bean en cours avec la laine de quel
animal fait-on des vêtements en
cachemire cachemires tension pouls et
cachemire à la chaire en cachemire ben
hassen bras oui c'est la chèvre bien
joué
[Applaudissements]
bassett